We are taking phone calls at six one seven
eight three zero.
Forty seven fifty.
Let's go to our caller from the two one five
area code caller from two one five.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
And David, this is John from Fulu.
John from Philly, what can I do for you?
Age.
I have two questions for you.
Yes.
Do you believe the bores are going to be open
in November?
Well, we know issues are all in my second
cause or.
Do you believe by that is going.
I gave up the throne.
We know by popular Rollerball.
No, by Atlantor Kobel.
By doing some kind of A-League.
My new more to win aim.
Biting not buzo.
Everybody not designed to do.
But it is going to get bored or he is going
to fighting for.
Okay.
Good.
Beautiful question.
So first of all, will the polls be open normally
in November.
The polls will be open in different states.
It's going to be a mess.
OK.
There are states where they are reducing the
number of polling places because of coronavirus.
I think we are going to see examples of everything
in November.
It's going to be a mess.
So my recommendation is I think the best approach
is vote early in-person.
Early in-person, I think is probably the best
bet.
But we've all just got to vote and we're going
to have a mess now.
Is Biden ready for a fight?
I. I sure hope so.
You know, we know that Donald Trump has lawyers
ready to go to try to stop absentee ballots
from being counted after Election Day.
Trump is ready with an army of lawyers.
Joe Biden had better have an army of lawyers
twice as big.
And, John, I worry that he doesn't.
I Joe Biden should be ready to fight.
I hope that he is.
I don't know if he is.
Very interesting.
Michelle.
John, where are you from originally?
Oh.
Oh, he's on gay boat.
I know, I know.
I just don't.
Where are you from originally, my friend?
Where are you from originally?
Domanick Gay Domanick.
Okay.
Very nice.
And you like Philly?
Oh, yes.
Nice.
I've never been, but I hear it's nice.
Yes.
All right, my friend.
So how are you voting?
Are you planning to vote in person?
I'm planning to go in person by.
I'm afraid that something's going to happen.
Yeah.
Well, if it does, let me know if there's irregularities
on Election Day.
You let me know.
Okay?
Yeah.
All right.
Oprah.
Thanks, John.
Final.
Do you have a wonderful day, sir.
You too.
Take care.
There's John from Philly, originally from
the D.R..